Peter Brown hey make sure how much for
joining us my friend we've a bunch of
stuff to talk about today you have a
console your PC between your legs don't
spoil it but first of all I want to talk
about this is a box that's on the table
so Amazon to finally release their at
touch to this am NOT kindle fire
explains it of focusing on what the hell
this is and why does she care kindle
fire TV is an android-based multimedia
entertainment device yeah I know yeah
that's really what it is man I mean so
basically this little box right here is
100 bucks it's linked up to Amazon's own
video services and you can watch netflix
and hulu but the big thing is oh we can
play games right and that's true it can
it literally can they will play games
with this thing that Chris has in his
hand yeah you can use this controller
right here but this is 40 bucks it does
not come included with a hundred dollar
package okay you can also use this
little guy to control game that's the
remote control for my stereo isn't it
yeah and it also plays games and I was
like a phone yes it does if you're Gary
so shade only well make julienne fries
what are you trying to say Chris yeah so
you know I mean we all like to hear
about new gaming devices right I mean
it's interesting to degree yeah but
haven't gotten over how cool the ouya is
right right amazon has picked up a few
different people they've got Clint
Hocking of far cry 2 Fame Kim Swift of
portal Fame they bought double helix the
team behind killer instinct on xbox one
yes and the new Strider remake but so
far the games that they have are rather
unimpressive let's say so what are we
talking about we talking about games we
talking about stuff that's out on
android phones are we talking about
console games coming to this thing a lot
of android stuff is available it's been
ported to amazon's marketplace you do
not get to use the google play store
which has the breath oh really love
android community right you do not okay
um and but yeah and then amazon like I
said they're investing in in bigger
games right now they have one called
sub-zero yes it's a tower defense like
third person shooter hybrid it looks
like a halo clone and obviously it's not
gameplay wise but you know it seems like
they're chasing trends that have been
successful in the past I'm not totally
convinced yet but they've brought a lot
of people on board right it just seems
like where's the niche that it's trying
to fill is it trying to give me a what
way to watch streaming video on my TV I
have like five of those yeah the tractor
me a new place to play games already set
like that what where what does it trot
what's where's the niche that like would
would be the peaking my interest I mean
you know we watch our hulu netflix
content on a game console right it
primarily for gaming we had that stuff
there it works it's great we don't to
change inputs we're good to go a lot of
people who don't play games might have a
Roku or some other device that or
that'll provide streaming services for
them or it just comes right into their
smart TV sure but those are typically
lacking in the little extra features
that make things you know really nice
they give this sort of like ooh factor
right with you with a new products yeah
yeah yeah every every amazon service on
this device has integrated really great
functionality including voice search
it's really good at detecting things you
like based on history like that's
nothing new but yeah it's all handled
really well and is a you know amazon
apps run really quickly on this the
downside is that the other apps don't
but anyway back to the point i think
that people who don't typically play
games want a better streaming device
than the roku yeah or something else
that's aging you know they'll pick this
up and then they'll figure out how it
plays games right and they'll play with
this you know there's six buttons on
here and like a directional pad and then
maybe the one upgrade i figured that's
what Amazon's hoping i don't think
they're tackling the typical console
gaming market but then in that situation
then why are they you know hiring all of
these people within the industry who
some would say are very respected like
the biggest names well i don't think
it's to attract people like us right i
think it's getting people who have been
taste makers who have done great work in
the past and it's probably you know sort
of like it's a pretty long bet they're
making right so if they can get people
interested in gaming they'll have these
people that are already there
establishing pretty good games so that
when they do want to make that leap
there's already stuff there for them
yeah i'm not necessarily convinced that
it's going to pay off in the next two
years right well I dipping their phone
from the water kind of seems like yeah
first and they've got money to play
around yeah I mean you know so the
benefit of the year would say is at
least that it's an android device that's
concentrating on games that just feel
like right maybe as an afterthought I
wouldn't say it's an afterthought but
it's definitely secondary to everything
else there is a lot of content that's
there but it's not necessarily distinct
from other devices just yet cool all
right
about the Amazon fire yes TV HD malarkey
what is this your between your legs sir
what do you think this is it looks like
a personalized computer yeah it's
exactly what it is what are you thinking
regular old pc it knocks well would you
believe it if I told you this is a
gaming PC that we built for the exact
same price as an xbox one that's a play
titanfall it might play titanfall I
think we've got some footage maybe
people want to roll that already walking
okay so is this a project you've been
working on yes myself and Mark Walden
our editor in the UK we both bill with
the computers that cost the same amount
as an xbox for that's after state and
local taxes at the highest you can pay
it's around 550 United States okay I
focus on insulin and video hardware he's
focusing on AMD ati stuff and later this
week on thursday hopefully we're going
to have a feature up that's blowing show
how well a pc like this can perform ah
we definitely had to you know we bought
windows no piracy loud yeah that's 100
bucks eating out of our budget damn yeah
and that when you're building on such
low cost that is a it's a pretty big hit
so where was the biggest you were the
biggest point in which you it's like cut
out of your budget for one for one piece
of the computer i'm assuming the
graphics card was probably one of the
major but the graphics card is is chief
yeah but then at the same time if you if
you spend all your money there you're
going to miss the other parts that
really support what the graphics card is
doing right you don't want a bottleneck
any part of it how much ram is in I'm
not revealing anything to say no looks
like you can have a look inside how much
did you spend on the case I was enough
quick releases it just des a case that
she does not have quick release no I'm
not gonna reveal any details that's the
whole point of the feature and i will
say that there are some very interesting
takeaways i was surprised for a lot of
different reasons it's got a 720 or PM
hard drive in there it's on SSD right am
i rise up I don't know at least give me
that theater now I can find out on
Thursday how accurate Danny peering
through D holes in a computer cases yeah
the gravity if anyone can recognize the
graphics card that's on that's got one
hdmi port one thing I don't know anyway
yeah I think this is really interesting
and I'm I'm really curious once I
finally put this together what how I
really feel cuz right now it's yeah I
can see the argument for a console NP
see at this price my favorite part of
this cheap case you bought is that it
actually does have USB and microphone
jacks yeah but also has this other flip
which just shows you the inside of the
computer no it's for your VHS tapes you
can just put it's trivia to put your
hand in there get it at your ram upgrade
your RAM and it having to turn off your
he does this before and you're gonna
fondle your RAM for like long minutes
and get your hand stuck yeah all right
so when's that up on the site thursday
we're shooting for thursday we it's an
international collaboration we're
working our hardest to get this done and
up on the site for everyone to see hot
collabos yeah i like if peter brian
thank you very much for coming on
you